[Musique]
anita turel présidente de l'olympic club
sa part on peut rêver les opa 63 ans les
retraités
parce que ça fait 40 ans que je suis
dans le faux tu veux pas lâcher et que
c'est mon club de coeur
loyal produit par rapport à mon club
parce que c'est
je suis membre fondateur de ce club
sincère intuitive aussi parce que il
faut absolument connaître qui n'a fait
rapidement dans le foot vous la houle
est souvent enfants c'est alors que les
gens les un petit peu hypocrite de céder
fois
[Musique]
ces matinées du batteur neil est fier de
voir madame anita turel comme présidente
déjà il y incarne la mère de famille est
comme un frère
c'est une grande famille elle a besoin
une femme comme une maman pour nous
donner des directives et aussi choyé les
joueurs et aussi mettre une ambiance
familiale au sein de du club
et quand on voit le travail que la
présidence fait et de la non-vie du
coaching
alors cette année ne l'envoyez un jeune
ne fait des essais à montpellier au et
il a signé un contrat pour trois ans et
d'ici juillet 2019 d'un lit sera
stagiaire pro à 17 ans morin ce serait
que le football dans l'es6 grandi que
nous ramène des titres dans l'est parce
que le football est comme un porc dans
le secteur continue avec nos jeunes la
formation des jeunes pour qu'ils
puissent v6 en ont la capacité à évoluer
dans des grands clubs
et puis toujours les amener à sortir à
ce que tu as côtoyé de notre niveau
[Musique]